اشهد ان
لا
اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الصلاه
حي على
الفلاح حي على
الفلاح
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
[Silence]
الله ان الحمد
لله نحمده ونستعينه ونستهديه
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات
اعمالنا من يهده الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل
فلن تجد له وليا
مرشدا واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك
له له الملك وله
الحمد يحيي ويميت
وهو على كل شيء
قدير واشهد ان سيدنا وعظيمنا وقائدنا
محمدا عبده
ورسوله وصفيه
وخليله بلغ الرساله وادى الامانه ونصح
الامه وكشف
الغمه تركنا على المحجه البيضاء ليلها
كنهارها لا يزيغ عنها الا هالك
صلى الله عليه وعلى اله
الطيبين واصحابه
اجمعين ومن سار على نهجهم الى يوم الدين
رضوان الله تبارك وتعالى علينا وعليهم
اجمعين ورضي الله سبحانه وتعالى عن سادات
ديننا امراء المسلمين بالحق ابي بكر وعمر
وعثمان وعلي
ورضي الله سبحانه
وتعالى عن الحسن والحسين وحمزه
والعباس وعن ازواج النبي امهات المؤمنين
الطاهرات من الادناس
والارجاع وعن بضعه الرسول فاطمه الزهراء
البتول وعن السته البرره الذين هم تمام
العشره
المبشره عن بقيه الصحابه والقرابه
والتابعين ومن تبعهم باحسان الى يوم
الدين رضوان الله تبارك وتعالى علينا
وعليهم
اجمعين فيا عباد الله اوصيكم ونفسي
المذنبه
الخاطئه بتقوى الله تعالى وطاعته ولزوم
اوامره وكثره مخافته اطيعوا الله والرسول
لعلكم ترحمون ايها المؤمنون
واعلموا عباد الله ان التقوى شعار
المؤمنين ودثار الصالحين ووصيه الله تعالى
في وفيكم
اجمعين اما
بعد قال الله
تعالى قد افلح من
زكاها وقد خاب من
دساها قال الامام الغزالي رحمه
الله ان كل نفس من
الانفاس
جوهره وان اليوم
والليله
ساعه
فتصور ان ينشر للعبد بكل يوم
وليله
24 خزانه مصفوفه
فيفتح له منها
خزانه فيراها مملوءه نورا من
حسناته التي عملها في تلك
الساعه
فينال من الفرح
والسرور والاستبشار
بمشاهده تلك الانوار التي هي
وسيلته عند الملك الجبار سبحانه
وتعالى ويفتح له خزانه
اخرى
سوداء
مظلمه يفوح منها
نتنها
ويغش
ظلامها وهي
الساعه
التي عصى الله تعالى
فيها
فينال من الهول
والفزع
ثم يفتح له خزانه اخرى
فارغه ليس فيها ما
يسره ولا ما
يسوءه وهي الساعه التي
نام فيها او غفل
او اجبل بشيء من مباحات
الدنيا فتحسر على
خلوها فيتحسن
على
خلوها قال احد
الصالحين
ه اي بمعنى
افترض ان المسيئ قد عفي
عنه
اليس انه قد فاته ثواب
المحسنين
وبهذا اشار الى الغبن
والحسره وقال الله
تعالى يوم
يجمعكم يوم يجمعكم ليوم
الجمع ذلك يوم
التغابن وهذا اخي
المسلم
كله مسجل لك او عليك في صحيفه
اعمالك قال الله تعالى ووضع
الكتاب فترى المجرمين مشفقين مما
فيه ويقولون يا ويلتنا ما لذا الكتاب لا
يغادر صغيره ولا كبيره الا
احصاها ووجدوا ما عملوا حاضرا ولا يظلم
ربك
احدا ايها
المسلمون على
المسلم ان يلزم وصيته لنفسه في
اوقاتها
ليزك ويرتقي
بها
وذلك
وصيه في اعضائه
السبعه
عين
الاذن
اللسان
البطن
الفرج اليد
والرجل
واعلموا ان لجهنم سبعه
ابواب لكل باب منهم جزء
مقسوم وان انما تتعين تلك
الابواب لمن عصى الله تعالى بهذه
الاعضاء
فيوصي
بحفظها عن
معاص اما
العين
فيحفظها عن النظر الى وجه من ليس له
بمحرم او الى عوره مسلم
او النظر الى مسلم بعين
الاحتقار بل عن كل فضول مستغنى
عنه فان الله سبحانه
وتعالى امر عبده عن فضول
النظر قال الله
تعالى قل للمؤمنات
يغضضن من
ابصارهن وقال تعالى قل
للمؤمنين يغضوا من
ابصارهم ثم اذا صرف العين عن هذا لم تقنع
به حتى
يشغلها بما فيه تجارتها
وربحها
وهو ما خلقت له من النظر الى عجائب صنع
الله بعين
الاعتبار والنظر الى اعمال الخير للاقتداء
والنظر في كتاب الله وسنه رسوله صلى الله
عليه
وسلم ومطالعه كتب الحكمه للاتعاظ
والاستفاده قال تعالى ولا تقف ما ليس لك
به
علم ان البصر
والفؤاد كل اولئك كان عنه مسؤولا
وهكذا اخي المسلم
ينبغي ان يفصل الامر عليها في عضو
عضو لا سما اللسان
والبطن اما
اللسان فلانه منطلق
بالطبع منطلق بالطبع ولا مؤنه عليه في
الحركه وجناته عظيم
[Silence]
كالغيبة علماء في الحلال والحرام عندما
سال النبي عليه الصلاه والسلام او او
نؤاخذ على ما نقول يا رسول
الله فماذا اجابه النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم قال ثكلتك امك يا معاذ ثكلتك امك يا
معاذ وهل يكب الناس على وجوههم وفي روايه
على
مناخرهم يوم القيامه الا
حصائد
السنتهم فهو بصدد ذلك كله مع انه اي
اللسان خلق للذكر
والتذكير وتكرار العلم
والتعليم وارشاد عباد الله الى طريق الله
واصلاح ذات البين وسائر
خيراته فليشترك على
نفسه انلا يحرك
لسانه طول
النهار الا في
الذكر الله سبحانه وتعالى يقول
فاذكروني
اذكركم وقال تعالى والذاكرين الله كثيرا
والذاكرات
فهذه الامور
كلها فيها
تزكيه
للنفوس وتطمين
للقلوب قال تعالى الا بذكر الله تطمئن
القلوب فنطق المؤمن
ذكر ونظره
عبره
وصمته
فكره قال تعالى ما يلفظ من قول الا
لديه رقيب
عتيب واما
البطن
فيكلف ترك الشره وتقليل الاكل والتحري عن
الحلال واجتناب
الشبهات ويقتصر على قدر الضروره
هكذا هكذا يشرط عليها في جميع الاعضاء
السبعه واستقصاء ذلك يطول ولا تخفى معاصي
الاعضاء
وطاعتها ندعو الله
تعالى ان يحفظ اعضائنا من كل معصيه ومن كل
فعل او قول مذموم واستغفر الله العظيم لي
ولكم ولوالدي ولسائر المسلمين اجمعين
ادعوا الله وانتم موقنون
بالاجابه
‏n